do you do when you look back did you
think that uh dawson's quick was going
to be a hit right right away i did you
did i did why is that because i didn't
do the pilot presentation i was off in
moab utah for five weeks doing the lost
treasure of jos santos with david
carradine lee majors kathy lee crosby
wow great
wow it's a movie that you will never see
i don't know i might now
they decided to go a different way with
the day after the pilot presentation and
after it was picked up
um
don't feel bad for that actor because
the next thing i know i'm sitting in a
movie with al pacino and he's so i got
dawson speak he got the movie with al
pacino okay so
well the tv show lasts longer than the
movie a movie is kind of there and it's
gone
it's true but i
they had me watch it the pilot
presentation and i knew immediately
and we forget this
uh because it became such a pop cultural
phenomenon we forget
how unusual
it was at the beginning to have a show
in which the kids
were talking like that were dealing
emotionally and internally with issues
and trying to express them in a
vocabulary that very few kids had i
remember a big star said to kevin
williams son one time kids don't talk
like that and without hesitation he shot
back maybe not that they'd like to
so
it was wilmington north carolina the
creek was an actual character in the
show the waters
of that you know uh southeastern coastal
waterway town
and
the issues that they were dealing with i
mean people forget it was the critically
acclaimed dawson's creek the first
couple of seasons sure yeah oh yeah and
i knew immediately i thought
wow
this is special and then i talked to
kevin williamson and he said
i promise i won't turn you into
i'm going to say the name of the show
because that sounds disparaging a
certain kind of tv parent
he said you will have real
subsidiary but independent storylines
that intersect with and
inform what the kids are going through
you won't just be mom and dad in the
kitchen stand have a good day at school
you know
and he was as good as his work you know
because there were
there were there was some really intense
episodes
yeah i even watched it i remember
watching i couldn't help but watch it i
had to watch that show
and i mean i ended up working with josh
in a movie called urban legend but did
you did you get along with everybody i
mean obviously you worked with james a
little more right
yeah yeah yeah i worked with james the
most it was interesting to see these
young actors and i think we were we
benefited from being in north carolina
out of the glare of la you know because
these
uh young actors went from
relative unknowns to
i mean
super star
and their faces on the covers of all
these magazines
that fast right you know and uh
to watch the way they handled it i mean
it was i mean i remember james when he
signed his first autograph had to go
tell mary margaret humes about it she
played his mom right right and when his
movie
varsity blues came out
his parents weren't in town so he asked
margaret and i to go with him to see it
wow
so that is pretty damn cool so he asked
his tv parents to go with him to the
premiere for varsity blues
that's pretty sweet that's pretty damn
sweet now i bet his parents were upset
they're like we would have come
jeez well it wasn't it wasn't the
premiere but it was showing right in in
north carolina you know
yeah
it was it was very very sweet but it was
also interesting to watch
you work with josh you know josh has a
very different way of working from james
who at that time was very cerebral
you know
very very emotionally logical
i mean uh i was watching this young man
of course he had worked with uh
uh oh god
edward albee
as a playwright on a play so i mean he's
he had he knew the work
and and he would have notes
after a script read through and some
people were offended by that
but
kevin williamson and i found this with
writers and producers who are really
secure
he was open to the notes he said yeah
but 98 of the time he's right
wow
you know yeah so um
but it was really interesting
and in the in the lives of those young
people to see how what they were playing
on screen was mirroring what was
happening off camera
you know what do you mean and uh what do
you mean
i'd say anymore well they were some of
them were seeing each other right
yeah
and they broke up and they got together
in different kinds you know was that
hard on set
was it was there like some stuff that
went on
i have a feeling
that by
fourth fifth sixth season a combination
of things happen number one they were
getting all these other offers right
they wanted to make
the leap to what was next and whatever
character
conflicts personalities
different way of working accommodations
that they had to make
to work with each other
uh
began to really grind on
to irritate
yeah